these are the images Brazil's
presidential walls Janero does not want
you to see
he says the fires that have been
affecting the Amazonian region happened
in the forested areas but this place
proves him wrong this is the father the
Kimo dies National Park in the state the
problem now is that 11% of it has been
devastated by the fire the government
has banned members of Brazil's
environmental agency from talking to the
press
org random access to locations like this
one Jorge we day has been living here
for over 30 years he says this is the
first time this area has been affected
by fire
I don't know why but there are branches
nearby maybe the fire came from the air
what's behind it is the attempt by
agribusiness to grow soya bean it's very
sad because this place is filled with
life they want to turn the forest into
money no matter what gets in the way
many here fear the president words when
he insists he wants to open up the
Amazons for business this area is known
as the doorstep of Amazonian the whole
region includes seven states in Brazil
the fires are still ongoing I'm not sure
if you can see but there's some smoke
right over there Bhanumathi moon has
been studying the rain forest for years
he says Amazonia needs to be protected
this tree like this this size this trunk
we have tons of carbon dioxide is
storage into these trees this act as a
filtering of excessive carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere as the amazon forest
can compensate all the emissions of
Latin America
Marie Montes Brazil's culture of
deforesting the region needs to change
because we have this culture to slash
and burn to create new year areas for
agriculture pastures
this meat and to produce soybean but
this culture we we have to change this
culture because
slash-and-burn is a very primitive form
to use the land each time the forest
burns it loses its capacity to absorb
the carbon dioxide blamed for global
warming
thousands of actors of forest have
already been devastated for now it seems
the force of nature will endure the
question is for how long
Theresa whoa al-jazeera chapada Dona
Maria is Brazil